yeah if god doesn't want me to find him
i'm not going to find it
assalamualaikum to guys make sure to
visit nature's blend for a 10
discount on fantastic sunnah natural
products
like these black seed and manuka honey
black seed oil
you got black season turmeric and many
other products hijab 10 for a 10
discount the link will be in the
description
[Music]
are you implying that the the christian
tradition
involves toilet paper in some way that
that
that uh uh nether hygiene
is somehow related to saint peter's
checklist
i don't know i know it's not it's back
now i don't
it's not so the first thing i want to
say is that islam as a religion
yeah it does deal with this issue of how
to clean yourself after you've defecated
why because it claims to be a
comprehensive way
of living at din which means a
comprehensive way of life
so the issue of how to clean yourself
after you've defecated
is one that islam actually deals with in
depth in so much as
it would tell you that after you've
defecated you should mix between
using water yeah to clean the area so
you talked about every day that's one
way a legitimate way of cleaning
yourself with water
even the b day suddenly the b day
is popular again i've never used one in
my life but
and using this is the best method
using also something like let's say
tissue paper for example yeah
but if you can't find the tissue paper
then you can use water so the whole
scare of
people getting uh panic mode because
they can't find tissue would have been
resolved if they just knew
the basics of islamic hygiene and i saw
people fighting
in supermarkets over toilet rolls
but the idea of cleaning yourself now
think about this i mean it might sound
quite trivial to you
to ricky but the truth is this if you're
playing football
and some mud came on you how would you
want to clean that mud off your foot or
your hand
or your face you'd want to wash it with
water likewise islam says the same thing
yeah when you're dealing with defecation
when you've done that you have to clean
yourself what
likewise urination once you've viewed it
you don't just wash your hands
don't just wash your hands islam says
you have to wash your private area as
well
and these are things which if people
internalize they'll have a much more
hygienic way of living
and they won't be in panic mode as we
have seen in the western world
within the situation with a pandemic if
they just have the basics of
how to live a hygienic life as per the
islamic teachings he can't prove the
non-existence of something
so he might be here and if he didn't
want me to find him
i wouldn't find him if you're an
all-powerful being
you are the best hide-and-seek champion
in the universe
so here as you can see he says that uh
to quote him
you can't prove the non-existence of
something
that's a very i don't know what
principle that is you've just said
something that doesn't make sense and
it's not true
because i can prove the non-existence
yeah of a squared circle impossible
things can't exist in the real world
so i can prove the non-existence of a
circle by the fact that there are two
contradictory things
it's the law of non-contradiction two
contradictory things can't coexist at
the same time
using this law of non-contradictions i
can prove the existence of something
which is self-contradictory i.e a
squared circle so this point here that
you can't
prove and uh prove the non-existence of
something is a full
is a false principle a fallacious
reasoning a false principle
that you continually say in all of your
discourse or many of your discourses
online
and it's high time now you realize that
you using these false principles in
order to
to arrive at disbelief is not helping
your cause
or your argument and if he didn't want
me to find him
i wouldn't find him if you're an
all-powerful being
you are the best hide and seek champion
in the universe
so here ricky gervais talks about well
he doesn't mention it as such but
it's the argument from divine
heightenedness so god is what if if god
exists and why we
why is he hidden from us in such a way
well actually i've
already discussed this in my previous
video god is not actually hidden from us
at all
god is a proto-knowledge an intuitive
knowledge
an instinctive knowledge that we come to
and arrive at from birth
and there is many scientific or
anthropological studies that
point to this direction we talked about
in 2011 the oxford anthropological
society and dr justin barrett
how he came to this conclusion using a
big study with a lot of people
children before they socialize that they
come to the
to the conclusion a proto-conclusion a
it's almost an instinctive conclusion
you could even argue
yeah or in his words an innate
receptivity to god
that's how he reflects he mentions that
a receptivity to believing
in the divine you you are born with that
okay and there's good evidence for this
so instead of just continually saying
there's a
god is hiding from us yeah you have to
now refute
that kind of evidence not only that but
you have to refute the demographic
evidence the sociological evidence and
the historical evidence
which not only show that god is
something which you are
born with as we've discussed or
believing in born believing in
but is something which is
cross-culturally accepted
i mean the idea of god yes there are
different variations or ideas
of what is god or what is the true god
and so on and so forth but the idea of
believing in a deity or divinity
that's something which human beings from
the beginning of civilizations
civilization have gone have gone more
with than without
they believe in rather than lack believe
in so this is the you're saying it's
high
it's high god is hiding i think you're
hiding in my opinion i think you're
hiding from the truth
you are hiding you see but the truth is
this is that actually god is not hiding
and that is why 90 of the american
public
till this day even with the spread of
say new atheism or this that or the
other
90 of the american public still believe
in a higher power according to pew
research
and only 5.5 percent of the british
public yeah are strident atheists
according to linda woods head and this
is all in my book the scientific
deception
of the new atheist which is free of
charge and the link is in the
description below
so you see ricky your face you need to
understand something that
your postulations yeah and your
arguments against the existence of god
are premised on false types of
principles that we've discussed
and weak argumentations so you're going
to have to come better next time my
friend honestly you're going to have to
come better than that
you don't you don't do the spirits too
dangerous i like i like a whiskey but
i think you've gotta do that very
sparingly
christmas when there's you know no i i'm
i'm a little bit scared of being that
guy that sits and
drinks whiskey you're talking about
that you don't want to be like someone
who drinks whiskey all the time in
spirits all the time because you
you probably visualize what that looks
like and you thought to yourself i don't
want to be i want i don't want to be
in a some ambulance state i don't want
to be i want to have my sobriety i want
to have my
cognitive functionality intact i want to
be rational
and you see that is the islamic
postulation or the prescription is
you shouldn't drink any kind of alcohol
at all
and if you look at the we're talking
about pandemics and we'll put a mask now
scared
of the situation with the covid
situation yeah that we're going to be
contaminated oh that will contaminate
others
and the risks on the nhs and so on but
what studies have already been done and
i'm sure there are there have been
studies in the western world
of the problems of alcoholism yeah like
how much
strain that's causing for the nhs how
many death related
incidents are caused because of
alcoholism how many lives have been
ruined because of
someone's constant intoxication
and you see you have to remember
something here that as human beings we
don't really have a
strict barometer for knowing what's
right and wrong
but what we can see is the consequences
of the actions
of of a country that or or a nation or
society
yeah that allows these kinds of
intoxicants
to be freely available for people you
have diseases that are related to these
things
so what islam says and this is another
point about guidance
is that we shouldn't drink that at all
maintain your sobriety
maintain your rationality maintain your
cognitive sharpness you're talking about
okay i'll drink this beer here
and i'll drink this wine here islam says
if you really want
to be rational enough yeah to be able to
practice your religion and to pray
properly
don't come near the prayer when you are
intoxicated until you know what's going
on
if you really want that cognitive
discipline
then you should abandon intoxicants for
good eliminate them from your diet
that's the situation here and you see
this brings me to another verse which i
think is very powerful in the quranic
discourse
which is in chapter 28 yeah of the quran
where god challenges human beings to
find something which is
more of a guidance than this book and
the torah
and the torah because we believe in the
previous dispensations before
it were corrupted the point here is
therefore
that islam offers you a solution
that is not only rationally yeah
satisfying but is spiritually nourishing
and practically applicable and with that
ricky gervais i invite you to read the
quran
and to be sincere and to try and find
the truth
and with that i'll see you later
you